In the invocation to book nine of paradise
lost. Milton describes, and it's a,
it's,
it's wonderful to see this representation
of this process that I think we've
been wondering about.
He describes the process by which the
heavenly muse inspires and he says
inspires nightly the
composition of his epic.
And he explains that the subject for
his heroic song and of course we'll be
getting to book nine later.
Uh, but it's, it's a, it's,
it's relevant for our discussion today.
Uh,
Milton explains that the
subject for his heroic song,
the subject of the fall of man pleased
me long choosing and to beginning late,
pleased me long choosing and beginning
late. And as we know very well,
Milton decided to write an
epic poem at a very early age,
but his decision to write an epic poems,
uh,
some epic long predated his sense of
what exactly that epic was going to be
about. He was long and choosing
the subject of his heroic song.
And as well as we know from all of,
and we've encountered a number of them,
all of those protestations of delay.
Milton began his epic late.
So we last left.
We last left the poet in a 1640s.
A area epigenic you'll remember
was written in 1644. Uh, the, the,
the story of Adam and eve and of the
end of the fall of Satan may strike us
having read or about to read paradise
lost may strike us as a natural subject
for Milton to have chosen for his, for
his epic poem. After all, this is a,
an extremely pious puritan,
but as late as the 1640,
this was not at all of the epics subject
that Milton was intending to use Milton.
And we know this.
Milton was a political revolutionary,
and when he anticipated
writing the great poem,
he consistently imagined
that it would be a poem on a,
on a nationalist theme.
Milton's would be an epic demonstrating
the origins and the heroic achievement
of his own, of his own nation, England.
Or maybe he'd be thinking a little broadly
of Britain, which is England, Scotland,
and Wales. And in this
respect, it would resemble a,
it would resemble a
Spencer's fairy queen or, or,
or perhaps more importantly,
Virgil's Aeneid other nationalist
epic's now Milton at the same time we're
talking about the 1640s had had been
contemplating writing a play and that was,
that was supposed to be a tragedy that
in some manuscript drafts that we still
have today. Um, he in
some manuscript drafts,
he titled This Prospective
Prospective Tragedy,
paradise lost and another drafts,
uh,
Adam on paradise on
paradise. Um, and by, by the,
by the time Milton and actually all these,
uh,
all of these early drafts,
these notes,
these outlines for this tragedy that
actually never seemed to have gotten
written, um, are, are
included in the Tyco packet.
But by the time Milton
begins writing his epic, he,
his plan for a nationalistic poem,
a nationalist poem,
and decides instead to use the subject
matter that he had been 10 intending for
that perspective, tragedy, paradise lost.
And so were the reasons for this really
enormous shift in plans and the enormous
shift in subject matter
are worth exploring.
Milton had devoted 19 years
to the world of politics and,
and a lot and a lot has happened since
the exuberant optimism of police,
of the political spirit that we see in
attract like, like area politica. In, in,
in 1649, the, this, the Great
Puritan Revolution reached, uh,
an unspeakable, a climax, a minority,
a minority government of revolutionary
puritans had effectively taken control of
the state.
And so the radical puritan parliament
voted to execute the tyrant,
what they consider to be the tyrant King
Charles the first and to establish its
own government.
And Milton participated with
a extraordinary enthusiasm
and considerable zeal in
the establishment of England's
new non monarchic government,
initially a commonwealth. And then
what we can think of as a republic.
He had been the foremost propagandists
for the, for the puritan side.
And he had not only written really quite
daringly on behalf of the execution of
this particular king, but he wrote
another pamphlet, iconic class DS,
which is included in the Hughes edition,
which is a shocking defensive,
just regicide in general, uh,
not just in England, but as a,
as a kind of political principle.
Milton probably around this time
around the time that he was writing and
finishing the regicide treatises
began to lose his eyesight. Uh,
this is the earliest years of the,
of the Commonwealth government.
Nonetheless,
even blind Milton could serve the
serve the new regime as both the state
licenser.
And I won't even get into the irony of
the fact that Milton seems to actually
become the license or the license or a
printed texts that of course he had seven
or eight years before,
so utterly abhorred in the area.
But Jenica he seems to have had
some work as the state licenser,
but also more importantly,
and this is a much bigger commitment
as the nation's Latin secretary,
which means that he would compose
and translate all of the, uh,
England's correspondence with,
uh,
with the governments on the
continent to and from Latin.
So up until the, oh, up until this
period, the early 1650s, Milton was a,
a devoted contributor to the
ideal puritan notion of this,
of this government. And it was really
the height of his political idealism.
Fast forward a few more years. By the end
of this decade, by the end of the 1650s,
Milton can see as good others,
uh,
fairly clearly that what we can think
of is the eminent collapse of the
Republican, of the Republican. Uh,
the majority of Englishman we're
calling for the return of their nations
rightful monarch. And it wasn't, it
wasn't long before the revolution failed.
And, and, and the Stuart
monarchy was restored.
The son of the executed king
who had been an exile and,
and France was returned
to the throne in England.
And so at the restoration,
as it's called the restoration,
which took place in 1660,
the puritan revolutionaries,
the revolutionaries like Milton who had
devoted their labors to the success of
this Utopian ideal of
the Puritan Commonwealth
experienced a humiliating and,
and bitter defeat. Um, a
lot of Milton's friends,
a lot of Milton's comrades were hanged
and quartered and Milton himself was
jailed and jailed for his,
for having written.
The regicide treatise
is we have to assume,
and it seems to have been solely the
influence of some important friends that
kept Milton from being held in prison.
And definitely,
and it's entirely imaginable that
Milton could have been executed for his
writings on behalf of the killing of,
of King Charles.
So it's at this point, this is when, uh,
this is when Milton begins. Finally,
this is after the revolution has failed,
that Milton begins to write as epic poem.
And it's at this point
that Milton to chooses,
chooses to write an epic not on a
nationalist theme as Virgil went on,
or as Spencer had done there,
there was simply no nation
worth writing about. And,
and all of Milton's labors in the cause
of liberating England from the tyranny
of monarchy had in some way could,
could,
could be construed as having having
been useless and all of Milton's
expectations that England
might actually be transformed.
And they were glorious expectation.
Did it transformed into something like
a pure it and utopia or even a puritan
paradise.
All of that had been destroyed.
And so it's at this point that Milton
shows for the subject of his era,
epic poem,
the subject of the tragedy that he'd
been contemplating for so many years.
The epic was going to treat the fall,
the fall of, uh, both of Adam
and eve, Adam and eve from there,
a blissful state.
I'm in Eden,
but also the fall of the rebel
angels after their failed revolution.
And there's a continual analogy
running through paradise lost.
And it's a very troubling one that
associates the paradise that man lost with
Utopian government that England lost.
And of course,
perhaps even more troubling is the
satanic parallel as well. And you'll,
you'll want to think about why Milton
seems so aggressively to invite the,
the association between the failure of
the Association of the failure of the
just revolution of the puritans.
Of course,
that's how he would see it with the
failure of the unjust revolution of the,
of the rebel angels under
the guidance of Satan.
Milton began writing his epic poem too
late to celebrate a virtuous political
realm. It's, it's, it's too late
for this to be a political poem. Um,
but paradise lost is, is, is late for
all sorts of reasons. It's a, it's,
it's late for some personal reasons as
well. Uh, Milton had been, as you know,
anticipating writing
this poem since he has,
since he was at least 19 years old,
but he didn't even begin to fulfill
what we can think of as his epic promise
until he was nearly 50 years old,
until he had actually lost the use of
his eyes and telling you could no longer
read until he could no
longer use a pen to write.
And finally, Milton's poem is late by the,
by virtue of the simple fact that it's,
that it's written in the form of an epic.
An epic might seen like a
great idea when Milton was 19,
but by the time Nelson gets
actually around the writing, it, um,
it's an entirely superannuated,
utterly outdated form. Uh,
there's of course the, the, the undeniable
fact that the greatest epics, the Iliad,
the Odyssey,
and then the Aeneid were all written in a,
in a heroic literary past that would
have struck anybody as is irrecoverable.
But even the modern practice
of epic riding or romance,
epic writing had basically
entirely fizzled out by the
end of the 16th century.
Um, then, uh, the, the Italians,
I'm thinking of Tesco and,
and Ariosto there,
there,
there had been a half century that had
passed since any great modern epic or
romance epic had even been produced and
there would have been a prevailing sense
and Milton has to have
been sensitive to this,
that it was simply to write too late to
write an epic of any kind on any subject.
Milton began his epic poem late.
So it's in,
it's relate in relation to all of these
forms of lateness that we can best
understand the, the opening
invocation of paradise lost. So look,
look at the first, the first lines of
the poem. This is page 211. And the hues,
um, and Harold Bloom has,
has, uh, has written,
and I think he's absolutely right that
Milton begins paradise lost with a
powerful defense,
a defense against lateness.
And it's this,
it's,
you can think of it as this reaction to
the problem of late and us that accounts
for one of the invocations,
most distinctive features.
And that's the repetition
of the word first.
You actually have the word first appearing
six times in the first 33 lines of
paradise lost. Just,
uh, we'll, we'll, we'll,
we'll do a little catalog of them of
man's first disobedience and the fruit.
That was line one. Of course, line eight,
that shepherd who first taught
the chosen seed, lily 19.
Now from the first west present,
go down to line 27. Say First.
First heaven hides nothing from my view
a line 28 say first what cause and line
33 who first seduced them to that revolt.
Milton is alerting us to the
significance of the word first. Um,
in the very first line in this wonderful
act of violating the laws of I ambig
pentameter. Then now the, the, the rhythm
of a true line of I ambig pentameter.
And there of course, hundreds, maybe
thousands of such lines in this poem.
Um, a true line of I amic pentameter
would run like this, you know, this Duh,
Duh Duh da Duh da Duh da Duh
da UN unaccented syllable
followed by an accented
syllable and that little pattern
repeated five times. And so with this,
I am bic template in mind with this little
paradigm in our head and we may feel,
we may feel metrically constrained to
read the first line of this poem like this
of Man's first disobedience and the fruit,
not an no hundred, hundred,
hundred of man's first
disobedience. And the fruit, it,
it sounds stupid. Uh, it,
it shouldn't sound stupid.
It's impossible to get away
with such an awkward reading.
But that's the reading that the metrical
form is pushing us into producing that
word first. And the problem
is with the, the, my,
my awkward metrically a proper reading
of that first line is that the word first
insists on being accented
and it screws up,
it screws up the template of man's
first disobedience and the fruit.
And so Milton is, is, is,
is rebelling against an implicit law of
poetic meter in the very first line of
what?
Of course we know we'll be
this extraordinarily self
conscious poem and you
could think of this as the poems first
by no means by no means, it's last.
It's first act of poetic disobedience.
Now the word first begins to take on a
a much bigger range of significance is
then we might at first think
when Milton instructs his muse,
say first for heaven hides
nothing. From my view, there's,
there's something more here than
the primary sense of the word,
which is just first in sequence.
And Milton of course is instructing the
muse to explain first before she gets
around to explaining anything else
what caused Adam and eve to fall.
That's just the simple
sequential sense of first,
the first that comes before
second, third, and fourth.
But there's something more radical here.
Then the ordinal or sequential sense
of first first can also mean earliest.
And Milton's describing his muse,
describing his muse now at
the present moment of the,
of the writing of the
poem to be the first one.
Perhaps ever to explain
the cause of the fall,
to be the first to tell the story of
the loss of paradise, or I don't know,
to be the first perhaps to be the
first poet ever to write an epic poem.
Milton's Milton's constructing a, it's a
remarkable and impossible strategy here.
And it's when we can call a strategy
of retrospective anticipation.
And it's a type of, uh, of course, this
retrospective anticipation can only be,
can only be a fiction one can never
come before something that of course has
already happened. Uh, but this
fiction of an impossible first,
and this is something that Miss Milton is,
is working very hard to accomplish
here. Um, and, and we know this,
Milton has already indulged this fantasy
of coming before something that's
already happened.
Um,
we recognize this desire to anticipate
and already existing narrative from,
from what? From Milton's
first major poem, the, the,
the naitivity own Milton directed
the heavenly news. In that poem,
you'll remember to prevent,
to come before the three wise men
who were, who were hasting to there,
to the manger with their gold and
their frankincense and myrrh. Oh, run,
prevent them with my humble load.
Have Thou the honor first by Lord degree
and I, and I suggest that we can,
we can hear some of the echos.
We can hear echoes of that same youthful
competitiveness in Milton's first major
poem in these opening
lines in the, in the, in,
in the beginning of the great
epic of Milton's maturity.
Milton wants to write an
epic that in some way,
in some ways comes before or prevents
the great epics of homer and Virgil.
This is it. Safe to say that
this is no, no, no easy feat,
no easy feat,
but as presumptuous is that desire is
to come before homer or to come before
Virgil.
It's by no means the final sense,
I think of Milton's ambitious drive
to be first. Milton invokes the seam.
Heavenly news here. Who Inspired Moses?
That shepherd? Look at line eight,
Moses, that shepherd who
first taught the chosen seed.
It's almost as if could this be.
It's almost as if Milton wants to narrate
the events of the creation and the
fall with the same kind of
firstness that Moses, Moses did.
Milton would of course,
steps have assumed that it was Moses who
had written the first five books of the
Bible, the Pentateuch, and
to prevent or come before Moses is a,
is an act of,
of prevention or anticipation,
far more dangerous. Uh,
then mere literary competitiveness.
Milton, what's Milton doing here?
We could see him as actually
vying with scripture and,
and implicit in this invocation is a,
is a truly remarkable claim that
this poem is the same product,
is the product of the same
divine authority that had
informed and inspired the
writing of the Holy Bible,
seeing heavenly muse,
that on the secret top of Oribella or
of Sinai did inspire that shepherd who
first taught the chosen
seed in the beginning,
how the heavens and earth rose out
of chaos or of Zion Hill delight.
The more in Siler was Brooke that
flowed fast by the Oracle of God,
I then invoke thy aid
to my adventurous song.
Now, Milton doesn't want, uh,
Milton doesn't want simply to be an
epic poet like homer and Virgil. Ah,
that, that's that. No sweat with that one.
But Milton wants to be a divine prophet
like one of the great Hebrew poets of
the Old Testament,
and this is why he's continually placing
the imaginative origin of the poem.
Back back to the very dawn of time,
perhaps even back before,
if you can imagine such a time
before the very dawn of time,
Milton wants to create the illusion that
he's predicting or that he's prophesied.
The actions recounted in the poem
is it Milton were prophesying what?
Of course we know to be already passed.
This is the strategy of
retrospective anticipation. Now,
Milton can make this implicit claim for
a prophecy because he's being inspired
by none other than the divine spirit
that had inspired Moses to sing of of
divine creation.
How the heavens and earth
rose out of chaos. This is
already an outrageous claim,
but Milton dares to go even further.
Now,
not only is this the same muse who ended,
had inspired Moses to
write about creation.
This heavenly spirit was actually
present at the moment of creation.
Look at line 17 and chiefly thou spirit
that does prefer before old temples,
the upright,
heart and pure.
Instruct me for Thou knowest thou from
the first wants to present and with
mighty wings.
Outspread Doug like sets brooding
on the vast abyss and made,
stood pregnant of of all
of the appearances of the
word first in these opening
lines, this is the first that
has to bear the most weight.
This spirit to whom Milton is praying
was the actual vehicle through
which God created the universe.
This is the spirit through whom God
fashioned the world out of chaos.
This is the spirit that Moses
says in the first book of Genesis.
This is the spirit that moved upon
the face of the waters at the time of
creation and Milton. Milton goes
beyond the image of this creation,
this creative power
provided for us by the,
by the King James Translation of the
Bible or by any English translation of the
Bible. In Milton's time,
he looks back even further.
Milton goes back to the
Latin version of the Bible,
which translates the Hebrew word
for move moved as in Cuba Bot.
That's Jerome's translation.
Uh,
incubate is the strange
Latin word and it's a verb.
Of course, as we know, it's
a verb typically used with
relation not to spirits,
but to just dating birds.
And it literally means to brood,
to incubate means to brood or to
sit on one's eggs until they hatch.
And so Milton's Holy Spirit,
the,
the creative force behind the entire
universe actually sat brooding on the vast
abyss sitting on the wall there.
Waters of chaos,
just as a mother dove might sit
on her eggs and, and Milton,
think of what Milton's asking us
to here. It's a, he's asking a lot.
He's asking us to imagine God or perhaps
this is God's creative spirit as some
sort of feminine being
laying the universal egg and
brooding over it until it
bursts forth with, with new life. I
remember Milton is, is this is a risk.
Milton's treading an extraordinarily
fine line between the,
the tremendous beauty of this image
on the one hand and what it's,
it's potential impiety or just
grotesquery on, on the other.
And no sooner is Milton conjured this
already unbelievable image of a kind of
maternal creation than he reverses all
of the gender categories that he's just
established.
And he adds to this image
that is perfectly sufficiently
filled with grotesquery
as it is. He adds this next
phrase and mates to pregnant.
I ran, how do we even begin? How
do we even begin to appreciate the,
the, this, this amazing imagery
here in portraying the deity?
Yeah,
I would think if I were to
write an epic poem, I would,
I would feel that I would be expected
to stay within the fairly narrow
parameters of religious, of religious
decorum. There's, there's no,
Milton had no precedent for this.
Um,
there's no precedent for this depiction
of a god or a Holy Spirit as a kind of
hermaphroditic being.
Um,
and I think it's safe to say that
were intended to be, to be shocked.
Maybe even we're POLST bye bye.
This remarkable description of the deity.
And so I'm hoping you'll feel
something of the shock of, of,
of these lines and mates.
Pregnant Milton and his is taking
a huge aesthetic risk here.
And it's always when w
whatever you're reading,
it's always worth thinking about and
considering what the motives might be
first.
The first such extraordinary literary
risk taking that they made this image of
the curious process by which the
heavenly spirit creates the universe is,
is absolutely central. It's
central to this poem. Um,
and it's central to the
poem for two reasons.
It's central to Milton's
theological debate,
a theological vision that will soon
establish itself throughout the poem.
And it's also, I think,
central to his poetic vision,
his vision of what a poem is or should,
should be.
And so shocking image,
this impossible to imagine image of a
brooding impregnation establishes the
foundation for, for two of the two of
this poem's most, most daring elements.
The first is the radical
theology and, uh, and,
and the second is this poem's equally
radical and equally daring original verse
form. Let's let, let's take the first
thing first radical, the radical theology.
It's, it's with, and
I'll just look at a all,
I'm only able to talk about a small
component of Milton's theological daring
here.
Um,
it's with this image of a brooding
impregnation that Milton announces the
presence in his poem of his most potent
when I think is the most interesting
theological, um, innovations,
the innovation that he
comes up with here. This is,
it seems to be the case that Milton
rather late in his life has become a
modernist.
He embraces the Hetero docs idea of Mon
ism or sometime sometimes called animus
materialism or vitalism,
which is essentially a denial
and denial of any distinction
between the body and the soul.
And so the principle of Moana Ism had,
had just introduced itself
in England around those,
around the mid 1640s, around.
It's been argued around the time that
Milton's writing area political and,
uh,
and it met with all sorts of opposition,
Orthodox scientists,
Orthodox Christians,
everyone agreed in the 17th century
that matter or substance a body was,
it was entirely separate from
and distinct from the immaterial,
the Incor pauriol stuff,
uh,
called spirit or soul and,
and so orthodoxy is definitively dualist.
There are two,
there are two types of stuff in
material stuff and matter or body,
but Milton insisted that there's no
such thing as an immaterial spirit,
that that was a contradiction in terms.
And so everything that
we call soul or spirit,
even God himself for John
Milton is bodily. Um, spirit,
spirit is mirror merely a kind of
bodily form of energy and, and, and,
and God at the beginning of time and fuse
this energy into the entirety of the,
into the entirety of the material world
at the creation. So physical life,
physical matter for Milton,
for the mature Milton has never
lifeless or dead. Uh, it's uh,
all matter contains within it
something like a potency of life.
That's Milton's phrase. It's,
and it has a capacity for action.
I actually a capacity
for motion and just as,
as books can take on a life of their own
and [inaudible] so all matter for the,
for, for later Milton, um,
even what we think in our vulgar
ways to be inanimate objects,
even they even,
they seem to have within them something
like a potency of a potency of life or
an infusion of divine spirit.
And of course the human
body is the perfect is the,
is the supreme example of the
spiritually infused corporeal substance.
Um, it's, it's infused with divine
spirit. Um, and, and, and this was,
this is a huge problem
in the 17th century,
Milton's contemporaries were endlessly
conjecturing where it is exactly in the
body that the soul resides. And some
of you may, may know that Descartes,
the great French philosopher,
Milton's slightly older contemporary,
had decided that the soul,
the soul resided in the pineal
gland of the, of the body.
The soul infused,
the sole managed to cover in the body
from this tiny little tiny little place in
the rears, the pineal gland. I think it's
in your brain, the back of your head.
Thank you. Um, keep that
and keep that in mind. The,
the soul for Milton though
isn't distinct from body.
It is the body,
the soul infused.
It's power throughout the entirety of
the bodily frame. And so bottle it,
body and soul in Milton's incredibly
moving and I think really beautiful vision
almost becomes indistinguishable. And
so all of this Mona's stick philosophy,
I think is implicit in the image of,
of divinities impregnation of,
of the vast abyss. Milton's God
doesn't, as we learned from genesis,
doesn't fashion the matter
of chaos with his hands.
He impregnates it with spirit and
he gives it a potency of life as,
as you'll see in book seven,
the book of creation.
He gives it a liberty to organize itself
into the order of the created world,
a freedom to create itself.
And now that's,
that's one,
that's one consequence of,
of Milton's Milton's image
of a brooding impregnation.
There's a second type of potency that's
also established in with this image.
And that's the potency of the kind of
verse that Milton is writing and paradise
lost. And, and, and, and, and
it's been argued, and I think,
I think there's something to this that
Milton's Moen ism is closely connected to
his implicit theory of poetry.
There's there,
there's no question that,
that the shock experienced by the
first readers of paradise lost
had next to nothing to do
with the content of this poem,
which might strike us as,
as, as shocking in itself.
We would think that Milton's
contemporaries might be, um,
might be aghast that such a,
such as sympathetic portrait
of Satan could be used at
the beginning of the poem.
No, it, the most immediately shocking
aspect of the poem was it style.
And, and, and we have to look at
the actual poetic form by which, uh,
this poem is constructed because it's,
the poetic form is absolutely integral to,
it's to, it's to its meaning. So
if you, if you don't, right? Uh,
and if you're not taking
notes in this lecture, um,
you have to write down
at least one sentence.
You must write this down because this
will be the most important thing I say all
morning.
Milton's paradise lost is
the first narrative poem in
English that didn't rhyme.
Milton Milton road is epic
and lines of unrivaled,
I am big pentameter or what we call
and what Milton would have called blank
verse. And up to this point, up to
this point and literary history,
only verse written for the theater
had had been written in this unrivaled
unrivaled lines of I ambig
pentameter in blank verse.
This is the verse form you'll read,
you'll recognize it in so
many of the long speeches of,
of characters and the plays
of Marlo and Shakespeare.
But all those are plays though
in all English narrative poems,
including all of Shakespeare's
narrative poems. Um,
they had all been written in rhyme,
either a long verse,
paragraphs of rhymed,
heroic couplets or in
intricately rhymed stances.
And so for most readers
in Milton's Milton's time,
Ryan was actually constituent IV of
poetry and Milton's lines of unripe verse
here may well have not seen poetry at all.
It was shocking.
And so there seems to have been something
of a kind of outcry about the style of
paradise lost and it look
at page 210 in the Hughes.
It's in response to what seems to have
been an aesthetic reaction to the poem
that the printer of Paradise lost ask
Milton went back to Milton and said and
asked him to append a note, two
et seq the book, second printing,
append to note that explains why
the poem rhymes, not, you know,
there's people can't deal with this
problem until they get that they can get a
handle on why the fact it doesn't rhyme.
So that,
so Milton Milton writes this and adds it,
appends it to all subsequent
additions of the poem.
This is,
this is what Milton tells us.
The measure is English or
work verse without rhyme as
that of homer in Greek and
a Virgil in Latin Ryan being known,
necessary adjunct or true ornament
of poem or good verse in longer works
especially,
but the invention,
and this has this so familiarly miltonic,
it's the invention of a barbarous age to
set off wretched matter and lane meter
Greyston Dean since by the use of
some famous modern poets. Okay.
Spencer might've done it kind of well,
the whole rhyme thing, but nonetheless,
the modern poets are carried
away by custom much to
their own vexation hindrance
and constraint to express many things
otherwise and for the most part worse than
they would have expressed them.
Milton brings to his critique of
rhyme that same and this is familiar,
the same political rhetoric that he had
brought to his critique of monarchy in
the,
in the regicide treatises and can also
hear Satan's Satan's critique of the
tyranny of heaven in, in, in, in these,
uh, in this account of the rhyme as well.
Like kingship. Rhyme is a custom,
it's an invention of a barbarous age,
which a blind and ignorant population
will exempt only to its own vexation
hindrance and constraint.
And it's always Milton's duty.
This is John Milton's.
The reason that he was put on this earth
is to liberate a people from any such
constraining customs.
It's the rhetoric of liberation,
that this is the rhetoric that permeates
all of Milton's political pros.
And so while Milton decided
against writing an explicitly
political nationalists
poem,
he didn't see himself as writing a poem
that performs some kind of political
function and it performed
it's revolutionary function
in a much more subtle,
though I'm much more
insinuating kind of way.
And so at the end of
this note on the verse,
Milton claims the Paradise lost
is to be esteemed and example,
set the first in English.
Another important first of ancient
liberty recovered to heroic poem from the
troublesome and modern bondage of rhyming.
It's a,
this is a, is is a wonderful
metaphor. Milton's thinking.
It's as if Milton is thinking of of the
poem as if it were a human body and the,
and the rhyme words at the end
of the typical heroic couplet.
Two lines that w that rhyme at the
end and then another two lines with a
different rhyme at the end of those two
lines. Um, he's, he's describing the,
these lined rhymes of the
poems by his contemporaries,
his competitors as the couplets,
the rhyme,
the rhyme words function as shackles.
I think that's the image here,
there manacles that confined the otherwise
vulnerable and tender flesh of the,
of the body of the poem.
Rhymes are barbarous forms of constraint
that impinge upon the true freedom of
the body of the poem.
And so that's why Milton explains
here in the middle of the note,
that's why other cultures have rejected
rhyme as a thing of itself to all
judicious ears,
trivial and have no true musical delight,
which consists only true musical
delight consists only an app number fit
quantity of syllables and the sense
variously drawn out from one person to
another,
not in the jingling sound of like endings.
So Milton refuses to force to force his
poem to make sense through the barbarous
mechanics of rhyme, which, which for
Milton reduces all of the spirit,
all of the life of a poem or of a line
simply to that jingling sound at the end
of the line.
And so when Milton's verse here,
sense or meaning is variously drawn
out from one verse into another,
since the very spirit of meaning is
infused throughout an entire line,
rather than being singled out
and separated or segregated, uh,
to the end of the line in
the form of the rhyme word.
So since in Milton's poetry functions
a lot like sole does or spirit does in
Milton's theology.
And,
and Milton's note on the verse clues us
into this intimate connection between
his radical poetics of blank verse on
the one hand and his radical theology of
Mona's among the other. Um,
you'll, you'll, you can, uh,
you can see from the handout
that I've, I've, I've given you,
I hope you can see from the handout that
I've given you a quotation here from
Milton's Christian doctrine. Yes. Um,
in which built and describes the process
whereby a God actually impregnates the
human body with soul. Nor did God
merely breathed that spirit into,
into man, but molded it in each
individual and infused it throughout.
The divine soul is everywhere in
the miltonic body, the human body.
And of course, that means that all
human acts are sanctioned by God,
including the, maybe most
importantly, the sexual act. Um, it,
it has given the highest form of divine
approval imaginable. And Milton wants to,
Milton wants us to think of the sense
of his verse as being similarly unfused.
The poem is similarly infused
throughout the entire,
with with some kind of soul or spirit
or divine energy throughout the entirety
of a verse.
Paragraph.
Milton refuses in paradise lost to
constrain a thought or to confine it to a
grammatical,
to a grammatical unit of sense.
He reframes a grammatical unit of sense
is never identical to align in Milton's
poem.
Um,
since doesn't simply end at
the end of a 10 syllable lines.
Now,
now most most rhymed poets
in poems in Milton's Day.
Uh, we're in stopped lines of verse and
an end stop line is one in which the
grammatical unit of sense stops
precisely at the end of the line.
So,
and the,
and the next line of verse picks up a
different thought and the next one after
that and, and, and so on.
And you can actually see the mechanics
of this of end stop verse quite clearly
in the Ryan version of
paradise lost that the great,
admittedly the great
poet John Dryden wrote,
this was supposed to be
the Libretto for an opera.
And Brighton seems to have gotten
permission from the old blind poet Milton
himself because Dryden felt that the,
the public had an interest
in reading paradise lost,
but they couldn't deal with the fact that
it didn't rhyme. And, um, it's a mill.
And so Dryden's set out on this remarkable
project of making the whole thing
where I'm, and I invite you
to, I invite you to read.
Dryden's efforts are
really quite remarkable.
It's not unlike with the Turner
Broadcasting that work does with, uh,
with old movies colorizing them in order
to make them more palatable to a modern
audience.
And you'll notice that every line of this,
of the passage from Dryden
here concludes with a,
with a comma or a period because every
line constitutes own syntactical unit of
meaning.
But Milton Milton's poem,
this is a statistical fact that that's a,
I don't know who came up with it.
Milton's poem has far
fewer end to stopped lines.
Then the verse of any other poet,
Milton's lines we say are in jammed,
they,
they run into one another and it's in
tactical unit for Milton is continually
spilling, spilling out. It's bursting,
bursting out of the line and infusing
itself into the next line and then into
the next and into the next. And I don't
know who came up with this statistic,
but I love it.
Nearly three out of every five lines
and paradise lost are in jammed.
The embrace, the practice of
in Jama, the meaning or the,
or the sense of inverse paragraph is,
is diffused throughout a series of lines.
And,
and I think that Milton
intends for us to think of,
of of the verse and Paradise Lost
as he wanted us to think of books in
areopagite Dukkha, the lines of Milton's
poetry or not absolutely dead things,
but they do contain within
them a potency of life.
So Milton,
imagine that his own verse was to be
read and experience something like a,
like a body. Of course, it's a
body that extraordinary that, that,
that enjoys an extraordinary
degree of freedom. And,
and is this a freedom that's infused
into the creation when the Holy Spirit
impregnates the
impregnates the vast abyss.
And this is also the freedom
enjoyed by the most remarkable,
surely hands down the most remarkable
of all of Milton's corporeal creatures.
And those are the angels. I imagine
it sounds strange to hear that, that,
that Milton is asking us in some way to
think of the lines of his poetry as if
they were the bodies of
angels. Uh, but, but the,
but the notion of corporeal freedom
is so central to Milton that that it
actually makes sense in some ways that
Milton would want to attribute it to all
of the most original in the most
daring elements of his poem. This is a,
this is our,
an argument that's developed,
been developed really quite brilliantly
by a great Milton critic William
Kerrigan. So a lot of book. One is,
is given over to the, as, as you know,
given over to those magnificent catalogs
of the names of the fallen angels as
Milton names, the demons, the
fallen angels and catalogs,
the names that they assumed when they
ascended to earth and took on the form of,
of, of, of Pagan Deities. Look,
look at line four 23 in book one.
Okay.
Oh, Erbitux. Even if you're reading
this for the second or the third time,
you were surprised again when you came,
you came to this point,
Milton Milton's been noting
that some of the pagan deities,
that the fallen angels eventually became,
were male and some were female.
And it's here that Milton for no
explicit or no apparent reason at all.
It's here that you provides a little
theoretical digression on the flexibility
of angelic bodies. Uh,
and in the context it's a,
it is a little gratuitous blind for 23
for spirits when they please can either
sex,
assume or both.
So soft and uncompounded
is their essence pure,
not tied or manacled with joint or limb,
nor founded on the brittle strength
of bones like come braze flesh,
but in what shape they choose.
The highlighted or condensed,
bright or obscure can execute their area
purposes and works of love or amnesty
fulfill. Clearly the angels
have bodies here. They're,
they're made of matter just
as, uh, as human beings are,
but their bodies aren't compounded,
have separable elements.
They don't have joints and
limbs or Oregon's or flesh.
They're nothing but a strangely
embodied form of pure,
pure spirit,
corporeal spirit.
That's a spirit that's been infused
through or loosely circumscribed shape.
Now we learned later that the fact that
these spirits can either sex assume
actually comes,
uh,
comes in rather handy as the angels
are permitted to experience a form of,
of sexual union that far exceeds the
miserable coalition that creatures like us
are forced to perform.
The coalition founded on the brittle
strength of bones Milton rights.
Milton's angels in an act of Sexual
Union are fully s smushed Felice smushed
together. They're an individuated, if
that makes any sense. In the act of,
in the act of sexual union,
there's is the unutterable sexual rush
that can only come about through total
corporeal in jam mint. Now this, this,
this little discretion
that Milton's give us,
given us here on the amber
sexuality of his angels,
not unlike perhaps the Amba
sexuality of his God seems to have a,
seems to have little to do with the
discussion at hand of the heathen deities,
but I think it has everything to do with
Milton's understanding of his own verse,
which he has freed from the bondage of
rhyming just as angels are freed from the
manacles of joints and limbs.
And so Milton's not only writing in
a poetic style that he thinks his is
politically motivated and ideologically
motivated and he is doing that.
But the style of paradise lost is
also powerfully eroticized for Milton.
And in,
in this,
in it's amazing malleability of form
having dismissed the manacle of rhyme.
Um, the, the, the, the poem
is teaming with the same kind
of erotic energy. This is,
I think,
Milton's fantasy from the poem that,
that same energies that charge that
image of books in, in Area Politica.
Um, let's, so let's look at how
this, an example of this might,
might actually happen. Um, uh, uh,
a way in which the verse actually seems
to this sensation of bodily freedom.
Just look at the first line of the poem
of Man's first disobedience and the
fruit. And, and, and we think it,
we think at first because we have
been so used before we read this poem,
we were so used to reading
end stop lines of verse
like the along the lines of verse that
all of Milton's contemporaries where
we're, we're, um, we're
just gorging. We assume,
I think after the first line or that the
line should be pronounced like this of,
of man's first disobedience
and the fruit of,
and implicitly given the
fruit of that disobedience
as if,
as if the line was actually an of
man's first disobedience and its fruit,
the fruit of the disobedience.
And we,
and we read fruit naturally here as
if it meant result or consequence.
But we find out, but we don't find
this out until we get to the next line.
That the fruit at the end of the line is
only a kind of temporary resting place.
It's a provisional, uh,
it's a provisional ending.
It's not a Ryan Ware.
And so it doesn't constitute the end of
a unit of sense as a rhyming word would
in most heroic couplets that the sense
of the sentence pushes us onto this.
And the next line,
which alters our view of the meaning
of the word fruit of man's first
disobedience and the fruit
of that forbidden tree.
The word is in figurative,
it turns out to be literal real fruit.
And we realize now that we've
only partially understood, uh,
that the sense of the word fruit,
it, uh, and the combination of,
of our readerly experience of the
two of these two lines. First,
the figurative reading that comes from
our habits of reading end stop versus,
and now the literal meaning of fruit
that comes from this newly acquired habit
of reading and Jam blinds.
Um,
it's the experience of both of these
cognitive sensations that that provides us
with the true signifying experience of,
of,
of what Milton can do
with a word like fruit,
which is obviously going to
be a loaded one in the poem.
Look at another instance of the
malleability of this, of this verse. Oh,
a few lines down.
Uh,
the heavenly spirit that ditzed inspire
that shepherd who first taught the
chosen seed in the beginning, how the
heavens and earth rose out of chaos.
Now at first,
I think Milton seems to mean that the
shepherd Moses inspired by the Muse first
taught the Israel Lights,
how the heavens and earth rose
out of chaos in the beginning.
And it was Moses who came up with this
phrase, Milton thought in the beginning.
That's the first, the first, first
words of the book of Genesis.
But Milton has clearly placed
this little phrase, this, uh,
this adverbial phrase in the beginning
in an awkward place. He frees himself.
And, and, and this is a, this
is an insight that William
Kerrigan has also had. Um,
he frees himself from the
strictures of conventional syntax.
Any places that phrase in the beginning,
at the beginning of the line,
very strangely, very awkwardly
before the how in the beginning,
how the heavens and earth,
and he's done this because he wants to
permit this phrase to do more than simply
modify the verb rose. We can also
see in this phrase in the beginning,
we can see it applying to the
end of the proceeding clause.
That shepherd who first taught
the chosen seed in the beginning
in the beginning can modify the
verb taught as easily as it can. Uh,
the verb rows,
it can either verb,
assume just as Milton's
angels can either sex as soon.
And there's an important point I think
that's being made with this second,
this second possibility.
Melton needs to imagine the narrative of,
of creation as if the narration itself
were taking place in the beginning as if
poetic creation could be a first in the
same radical way that the creation of
the entire universe is
obviously a first. And, and,
and this is a strategy called
a, uh, uh, double syntax.
The notion that in the beginning can
modify one verb or, or the other.
And it's,
and it's just this kind of rhetorical
trick that Milton uses so many rhetorical
tricks like this,
that Milton we'll use throughout the
poem that led Dr. Johnson to say an utter
exasperations, but admiration
that Milton wrote no language.
This is an English that Milton
is writing here. Um, they,
Milton's language doesn't have the
same kind of headlong rush that most
declarative English sentences have.
We're continually being prevented from
reading the text to get to the end were
prevented from rushing to the end of the
sentence or two, the end of the poem,
because at least as far as the,
well, you can think, you can,
you can understand why as far as the
plot goes, we know how it's going to end.
We know of course that Adam and eve
are going to eat the stupid fruit,
but Milton is developing a style and
he's working really hard to do this.
That works to resist our drive to get to
the end of this story and it's through
a mechanism of an entirely new verse,
a new kind of verse,
lonesome weaves into the
metrical fabric of the poem,
a New Perspective on that
old theological problem of,
of human freewill and
divine foreknowledge. Um,
can it be said that we actually
chose to sin or to eat the apple?
If God had known all along how the
story would end or that we would do this
thing in the first place?
That's the conundrum that on some
level we've all confronted and, and,
and has been confronted since,
since time began.
But Milton knows that if this
poem is going to be successful,
we cannot as readers be permitted to
think this story had to be what it was.
We can't be permitted to think that the
story had to turn out the way it did.
Uh, we need to think that
the actions in this story,
we're in some way free and
absolutely perfectly undetermined.
We need to get at the story of the fall
from the perspective of its beginning
rather than from the perspective
of its of its ending.
And so Milton and fuses this angelic,
this angelic freedom,
and he infuses this bodily liberty into
the actual body of the verse itself.
Of course, to make a point.
He's incorporating his style,
a radical, original style into the,
into the essential argument of the,
of the poem.
And he permits his own
unconstrained indulgence in,
in poetic, in Jama. He permits in
Jama to become the verbal medium.
This is the,
the pulsating vehicle for his
precious theology of freewill and,
and for his politics of
liberty. Okay. That's the end.
I want to remind you a final
time to look at your Spencer, uh,
the Cave of mammon episode as well as
Doctor Johnson's brief comments on sin and
death.